but this is a really big year for you it
is yeah did you know that
no really
i mean
like why would i know that
hello welcome back to another episode of
horoscope it out my name is elisa kelly
and i am in
a sandwich i'm the meat of a really
exciting sandwich and i cannot wait to
look at these charts awesome what kind
of bread are we
we have a pisces and we also have a
taurus variety
it's gonna be a delicious meal so rachel
did you know that you're a pisces
someone once told me that i was a like a
sextuple pisces yes they were right okay
um you are a pisces son you are a pisces
rising you are a pisces mercury you are
a pisces saturn you are a pisces mars
you are a pisces chiron you are a pisces
juno and you are a pisces moon well i
don't know what that means but it sounds
like i'm very magical it's and that is
exactly what a chiron is okay
you don't often see this kind of lineup
with so many planets concentrated in the
same sign so to have this in your chart
is really it is a superpower it's it's
really special it's really magical and
your ability to connect with people is
really meaningful because of all of this
now that's not to say it's always easy
there are also some planets in here you
know such as saturn which is the planet
of rules and restrictions and mars which
is the planet of sort of action and
momentum and chiron which is a deep
wound that might complicate that
intuition and might not
might make it feel like it's not always
safe for you to fully surrender to what
you already know however when you work
with all of these planets there is this
it's like you can
predict the future you can read people's
auras maybe you could even commune with
uh
people on the other side really yeah
but it's really i mean this is a
profound amount of energy to be
concentrated in a certain area so it
takes something really monumental in the
sky to activate this
and i like to say this thing called
there are no coincidences it just so
happens that this year we have jupiter
the planet of expansion in pisces for
the first time in 12 years
going through all of these planets so
every single one of these planets is
going to get activated by this planet of
abundance
and it's
it's going to make things really happen
i think something has already happened
or is about to and there's no doubt that
this is going to be a year that is that
you really remember and that has really
a very
monumental lasting effect on your life
in whatever way you choose the cool
thing about having all of this in the
first house which is the area of your
chart around your identity is that there
is a you have choices you can sort of
choose how you want to work with this
energy and how you want it to enhance
your life so it could be
professional it could be personal it
could be about um how you
changing your sort of perception or how
you interact with other people i have a
feeling that this is going to come by
way of a very
unexpected
magical
opportunity uh that somebody it just
sort of drops on your lap well this is
weird but just this week i got offered a
broadway show really like two days ago
like on the blue house
like i've never done broadway so that's
like a big deal to me you know that is
what just happened well congratulations
yeah that's one thing i don't want to
say one little thing but i mean that's
one big thing but out of who knows this
is going to be a game change year
yeah
wow
i'm gonna leave here with bolster with
the power of jupiter like nothing can
stop me
[Music]
yeah this is really phenomenal we're all
three pisces moon
which is just that i guess that's the
sandwich what does that mean when you
have your moon in something so your moon
is your emotional inner world it is what
is happening on the inside intuition and
creativity a lot of a lot of writers are
have pisces yes or or
right yeah writers performers
musicians
creative people
because the pisces energy is very much
about
all things that exist in the
subconscious so it is very dreamy it is
very ethereal it is very fantastical so
big imagination the other really really
cool thing is that this year in 2022 we
have jupiter and neptune making a
connection in pisces for you that is
going to be right on
your chiron right next to your moon
right next to your juno and that
connection only happens every 144 years
and the last time that it was in an
opposition was actually the wizard of oz
so it's kind of that same you know from
black and white to technicolor energy
that we're going to be experiencing this
year uh with this beautiful jupiter
neptune conjunction so anyone with
pisces placements is going to be really
feeling this opportunity open up can i
ask a question are pisces indecisive and
chaotic
yes yes okay i just i'd wanted that like
confirmed
because i'm always like oh i'm a pisces
i lost my keys i'm a pisces and then i
was like is that part of it or is that
just my excuse for when it's probably a
little bit of both
no but pisces um are very much sort of
they're represented by two fish swimming
in opposite directions
one is moving towards the physical
real world and the other is towards the
ethereal astral
you know non-physical realm so pisces
energy is always sort of straddling and
riding that line between what's real and
what's not real so it makes things like
keeping track of your keys impossible
impossible
too mundane okay
rachel is four triple pisces i think
pretty she's so she can be very
structured about things too i mean or
can like meet deadlines and things like
that if you just completely surrendered
and succumbed to this you would be
take to your bed you'd be a mermaid
you'd be fully just in in the siren
waters of fantasy so there are certainly
things that anchor you back to reality
and i would say a lot of that you know
one of the things that's really cool
about your chart is that it has and you
can see it has this beautiful square
here so you have what is called a grand
cross in your chart in the mutable
placements so it's between the pisces
your jupiter and gemini
all of these planets in virgo and then
your mid heaven which is your career
your legacy how you're going to be
remembered and that's in sagittarius
which is really um
expansive you know it's about
it's living larger than life it is
challenging the status quo it is pushing
boundaries so
this square this grand cross that you
have in your chart is is really like an
engine that fuels you so even when you
get stuck and even when the
sensitivities start to go into hyper
drive there are other things in your
chart that kind of pull you out of that
awesome yeah does that resonate with you
i mean this is a broadway show that's
like incredible i mean having a great
year ahead yes that runs
i wanted to resonate so that's really
interesting wow yeah thank you this is
going to be big
so there we have it another episode of
horoscope it out what else is there to
say thank you both so much thank you so
fun
[Music]
so your year ahead yes yes tell me
you're going to feel the shift
internally as opposed to externally
first this is going to be something that
does require that sort of compromise
scorpio is the
c
yes it is i never thought i was gonna
have to say that on camera
[Music]
you